welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness gave us our first ever mutant
appearance within the mcu with professor
xavier's absolutely mental mutant
abilities blowing our mind shortly after
wanda blew black bolt's mind technically
he blew his own mind but
he didn't have a mouth that man is gonna
need a tylenol holy [ __ ] where's the
tylenol but while we did see all of this
gnarly carnage in the illuma lobby what
we didn't see in this movie was the
introduction of mutants in the mcu like
a lot of people expected to see the
arrival of the x-men to the mcu proper
by the end of this film but all we got
was a priceless pizza papa punch line of
a post-credits scene so this all begs
the question like where in the
illuminati sewer system are you hiding
all of the gifted children marvel
because it's high time then x-men showed
up for first class
well what if i told you that kevin feige
has been planting the seeds for the
x-men as early as freaking iron man 3.
what if i told you that huh well allow
me to show you why my nerd babies but
before i do make sure you head over to
new rockstarsmerch.com to pick up our
latest obsession shirt inspired by
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness the design is really dope like
it always is and these shirts like
always are not gonna last forever
because they're gonna disappear like
these shirts are too hot you can't keep
producing them we'll get robbed the
factory will be broken into you can't
have them making these shirts forever so
head over to rockstarsmerch.com to pick
one up today and thanks to onyou for
sponsoring today's video now we all know
from the x-men comics and tv shows and
cartoons that the main reason that there
are even x-men in the first place is
because of a little something called
human evolution you ever heard of it
you know the main focus of marvel
studios is very tale of the evolution of
mcu humanity that came in the form of
chloe zhao's incredibly symbolic
eternals film a film which saw these
celestial servants guiding humanity's
evolution after waking up on the domo
parked in front of the sun at the
beginning of the movie absorbing all of
that sun's energy and transferring all
of that sweet golden cosmic energy into
the eternal's android bodies and i
believe that it is this energy that
allows the eternals to do all of the
incredible things that they can do like
lie shoot laser beams run fast control
mines heal people cast illusions etc
because this energy is the goldeny
orange singularity of the soul
singularity or soul singularity as an
sol soul very clever and this
singularity is the singularity of life
evolution and survival in the mcu it's
what sets the people of mcu earth apart
from the rest of the universe like it is
our tenacity to overcome any obstacle
that has basically been growing within
mcu humanity ever since the first fish
walked on land due to the solar
radiation from earth's soul the sun the
very source of human evolution itself in
the mcu and this is likely what will be
the catalyst for the trigger of the x
gene within the marvel cinematic
universe when humanity finally enters
that next step very soon probably in one
of their most highly anticipated titles
guardians of the galaxy volume 3
specifically with the introduction of
the high evolutionary who i believe
chikudi iwuji will be playing in that
film an introduction that will likely
serve as an explanation to how rocket
raccoon was evolved from a lower life
form which is something that was implied
guardians of the galaxy vol 1. and why
he stole those harbullary batteries from
the golden sovereign race in guardians
of the galaxy vol 2. because minor
babies in the marvel comics the high
evolutionary famously began his studies
on human evolution through his study on
rats using science to forcibly evolve
these rats into humanoid versions of
higher evolved animals who herbert
windham the high evolutionary would call
his new men and make them serve him on
his spaceship laboratory in space and i
believe that rocket raccoon is actually
one of these new men who originally used
to be a rat because remember a long time
ago on twitter when james gunn said that
if you're really really really smart the
answer to who created rocket raccoon was
hated within guardians of the galaxy vol
2. well i believe that this is why one
yondu udonta repeatedly repeatedly calls
rocket raccoon a rat in that film and
why rocket raccoon steals the golden
anulax batteries from the snobby
sovereign whose entire society revolved
around them evolving themselves to their
most perfect form evolution because much
like i outlined in the past in that you
know marvel trigger theory video that i
always bring up about the purple cracks
in spider-man away home i don't believe
the sovereign live on a planet at all
because i am convinced that the
sovereign actually live on six huge
orange suns which generate the evolution
energy they need to evolve themselves
and make the mcu's ultimate evolved life
form and guardian of life adam warlock
because these motherf live on a little
something called dyson sphere which is a
dome of an invention that scientists
have theorized could harness the power
of our sun and launch humanity's
technological advancements to freaking
infinity and beyond and this is why the
entirety of their home planet has this
weird glow and these golden lines around
it the sovereign literally live on six
sons of evolution energy definitely
making me feel like these guys are
secretly the light elves of the mcu
because we have the dark elves we
haven't really seen the light elves by
name and i think the light elves are
just the sovereign that we just haven't
seen thor meet yet and maybe thor will
meet them in 4 4 who knows did you know
that 65 of americans don't have the
funds to pay for a financial crisis and
62 don't have an emergency fund as
someone who's had a few emergencies pop
up in my life i can tell you that they
don't usually send you a calendar invite
or call ahead to give you a few months
prepare i recently learned about a
company whose mission is to solve this
it's called on you and they believe that
everyone deserves financial security so
they're launching a membership helps you
create a plan based on you and your
goals as an all new member you just pay
one small monthly fee and you get a ton
in return a personalized financial plan
guaranteed life insurance a savings
account and a credit card that helps you
build credit instead of debt anu is
launching in june and they're having a
fun sweepstakes to celebrate all you
have to do is sign up for their wait
list so you can be among the first to
know when they go live and you'll also
be entered to win twenty five thousand
dollars just go to onyu.com that's o n u
dot com or click the link in the
description and thanks again to anu for
sponsoring this video but anyways let's
head back to the eternals real quick
because we gotta talk about what are
technically actually the first mutants
that we've seen in the mcu the deviants
because this evolution energy that lives
inside every deviant is exactly why the
deviant race went bad in the first place
and why the main bad guy crow was able
to evolve after ajak and gilgamesh give
him that sweet sunny delight to drink
out of he popped in the whole
the bodies like a capri sun and it was
like delicious
unleash the power of the sun that's
because there's a delicious ray of
sunshine in every drop
and the reason why those deviants
started becoming predators on earth in
the first place is because as irishmen
puts it they all had a flaw in their
design and i believe that this main flaw
was that aeroshem gave them bodies
capable of absorbing solar life
radiation and they wanted more of that
radiation and they wanted to eat more
terrans as terrans have spent all of
their lives absorbing that radiation
that solar life radiation forcing
aeroshim to develop the eternals with
their special bodies incapable of being
affected by the evolving properties of
the cosmic radiation that they wield
which is why none of the eternals could
age because aging in itself is evolution
but fortunately for the eternal sprite
cersei had enough juice to use her
transmutation powers to change sprite's
eternal body from the material that
eresha made it out of to human flesh
capable of absorbing that evolution
energy which now allowed sprite to age
and die eventually now considering all
of this let us also consider the actions
of a man by the name of aldrich killian
and his super volatile extremist program
which caused a bunch of desperate
veterans to explode from
experimentations on the human brain that
were meant to unlock the next stage of
human evolution specifically by
harnessing human bioelectrical potential
a potential that causes extremist
soldiers to be able to regenerate limbs
and shoot orange energy out of their
mouths like a freaking dragon and this
is all because as aldrich killian says
extremists harnesses our bioelectrical
potential
and it goes
here
this is essentially an empty slot and
what this tells us is that our mind
our entire dna in fact is destined to be
upgraded killian was basically using
science to tap into the solar evolution
life radiation inside of the human body
to trigger their amazing abilities that
look like magic but is actually very
much mcu science hence why it was in an
iron man film and hey do you know what
life radiation sounds like how i don't
know
vita rays like the kind that evolved
captain america's muscles when he used
it in conjunction with erskine's serum
and this would explain why johnny
mayonnaise and the flag smashers didn't
get yokes like steve from the war
because their muscles didn't get evolved
through that sweet x-men type evolution
energy so they just looked normal and a
lot more mentally unstable let me tell
you that because they didn't have vital
rays in their body
so this all being said kevin feige and
the gang at marvel studios are very
clearly focused on evolution and the
eternals project and their upcoming
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 are phase
four's attempts at getting us ready for
a massive event that is going to make
puberty really weird for some mcu
teenagers really soon before they all
have to save the world as mcu's uncanny
x-men and i believe that it will be
through guardians of the galaxy vol 3's
high evolutionary that evolution will be
triggered at least on a global scale
finally awakening mutant powers in the
mcu and boy can i not wait to see it
because we need my boy gold balls in the
mcu where the gold balls at i don't know
i don't really care about gold balls i
just think his powers are funny
but that is what i believe the mutant
plan is for the mcu what do you guys
think let us know in the comment section
below but anyways thank you guys so much
for watching this video you can follow
me at mastertainment on twitter if you
want to see me tweet some really weird
[ __ ] and insane theories but more
importantly you can follow new rockstars
wherever we are on social media and when
you do on youtube make sure you hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload which
is pretty dang often and again hit up
new rockstarsmerch.com you can buy our
latest obsession shirt inspired by dr
strange the multiverse of madness it's
not gonna last forever pick it up today
but anyways thanks again for watching
this video i love you guys so so so much
so much please take care of yourselves
and i'll see you guys next time
[Music]
you